on est solidaire parce qu'on défend une
chose qui nous est fondamentale libre
passionné accro à la polémique Denise
Bombardier aura été présente dans
l'univers médiatique pendant 4 décennies
ce n'est qu'un discours de façade son
décès à 82 ans est inattendu avant nous
manquer parce que il y en a pas beaucoup
comme il y a 10 jours elle était encore
très active elle travaillait etc et tout
à coup on apprend qu'elle est morte
en 1955 et l'église déjà ses talents
d'interviewers à l'émission où les ondes
enfantines à Radio-Canada c'est là
qu'elle plonge dans le journalisme
quelques années plus tard comme
recherchent à l'émission Au télévisée
aujourd'hui
avec noir sur blanc elle devient en 1979
la première femme animée une émission
d'affaires publiques c'est à ce moment
qu'elle établit son style c'était une
femme qui n'aimait pas la rectitude
politique qui n'aimait pas le silence
imposé qui s'exprimer des Français elle
est invitée en 1990 sur le plateau de
l'émission apostrophe de Bernard Pivot
de Nice bombardier s'en prend à l'auteur
Gabriel Martinez moi monsieur mazneff me
semble pitoyable ce que je ne comprends
pas c'est que dans ce pays il le
comprend parce que la littérature a une
sorte de Haïti c'est que dans ce pays la
littérature entre guillemets certes
d'alibi à ce genre de confidence
français Gabriel Martinez qui tenait des
propos ma foi carrément pédophile dans
dans ses livres dénoncer ces paroles là
elle le fait dans sa face devant lui sur
un plateau super masculin encore
l'étaler dans le Boys Club puis elle a
mis une bombe là dedans ces propos
polarisants étaient devenus sa marque
peu importe le sujet que ce soit sur
l'avenir du français au Québec ou sur le
féminisme à l'ère du mouvement moi aussi
si les femmes s'aimaient plus ça fait
longtemps que le féminisme aurait eu
aurait eu des victoires un ton tranchant
parfois dur à l'image de la femme libre
et entière qu'elle était je provoqué de
l'envie
parce que je m'exprimais ici Gabriel pro
Radio-Canada Montréal